welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday
my name is Whitley Tallmadge and today I
will be talking about dialog flow you
can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them let's get started
I'm Whitley Tallmadge I am a customer
engineer for Google cloud and I will be
talking about how to build
conversational experiences with dialog
flow using Google cloud platform today
so I'll be providing a brief overview of
dialogue flow Google's conversation
engine and a preview of our upcoming
Coursera course called building
conversational experiences with dialog
flow I'll demonstrate some of the basic
features of dialogue flow and a few
Google cloud platform products using the
quick labs platform I'll go over the
free training offers we have available
as part of this session to get you
hands-on with dialogue flow and as I
mentioned we'll also be answering the
questions that you submit in this course
we take a look at how to build engaging
conversational experiences using
dialogue flow we start off by using
dialogue flows building blocks to create
an agent step by step by defining user
intents extracting potential entities
maintaining the context of the
conversation as well as being able to
perform fulfillment actions outside of
dialogue flow for example storing data
pieces from the conversation into a
database we have plenty of demos that
walk you through each of these steps and
then have you do the same through a
series of hands-on labs at the end of
which you get to test out your chatbot
next we discuss a number of themes that
are important when you want to take your
chat bot to production like being able
to add basic authentication customizing
your chat BOTS UI deploying fulfillment
code on scaleable serverless
architecture and leveraging existing
sources to automate parts of the agent
building process towards the end of the
course we also talk about how to
integrate your chat bot into other
channels or surfaces like the Google
assistant and we also touch on a few
other additional functionalities that
can make your agents smarter and even
more engaging
to achieve the learning objectives
discussed the building conversational
experiences with dialog flow course
consists of these five modules building
conversational experiences with dialog
flow defining intents and entities
maintaining context in taking action
taking your chatbot to production and
additional functionality conversational
experience is the descriptive
comprehensive name for a new class of
solutions that include chatbots
conversational apps and other similar
terms dialog flow is a tool that can
help you build smart conversational
agents dialog flow is an end-to-end
developer platform for building natural
and rich conversational experiences at
its core dialog flow is a powerful
natural language understanding engine to
process and understand natural language
input in other words it lets you easily
achieve a conversational user experience
by handling the natural language
understanding for you using dialogue
flow you can build conversational
experience as faster engage end users
more efficiently and maximize reach
across geographies and platforms by
leveraging these capabilities and what
the developer provides as input training
data dialogue flow creates unique
algorithms for each specific
conversational agent under the hood
which continuously learns and is tweaked
for you as more and more users engage
with your agent some conversational
agents exist for very specific very
simple use cases with few intents and
minimal dependency on communicating with
back-end systems or knowledge bases
while some have multiple intents dealing
with more complex domains and backends
but typically the workflow to get your
conversational agent up and running maps
out to these three phases design what to
build develop how to build and deploy
how to deliver keep the style guide in
mind as you design your agents responses
for the best user experience you
probably don't want your agent to sound
too formal or robotic for example to
make your agent more REM
of actual human conversation you might
have it say something like does that
sound good rather than something like if
you feel you have reached this message
in error creating your dialogue flow
agent all starts with intents intents
are the trunk of the dialogue tree they
connect all of the branches intents
determine where a conversation will go
and what an agent should do in
communication intents can be thought of
as the route verbs in the conversation
such as one in coffee translating to
acquiring a beverage sometimes the
intents are not explicit and instead are
inferred from the entire composition of
a phrase you want to map your intense to
the goal of your application if you are
a helpdesk application then your intents
might include opening and filing a
ticket updating a ticket and closing a
ticket but your application may also
need to access and update a user's
account information branch over to a
live technician and even pass along a
quality assurance survey even
affirmation answering yes or no is an
intent intense evolved as your
understanding of the users needs evolves
and you may find yourself doubling or
tripling your intense beyond your
initial set of intents to make the task
of defining intents easier some rules of
thumb can be applied first identify the
verbs in the dialogue people will have
with your agent doing that will allow
your agent to have its actions mapped to
needs from the user another possible
scenario is to identify where the
application should branch logic here are
some examples - mocha coffees please how
many calories in a slice I want a pizza
or even I really need some caffeine once
you have chosen your intents you need to
train your agent to recognize them this
can be done with the use of training
phrases the training phrases for each
intent should be representative of how
users will say the intent it is always a
good idea to add variations to the
grammatical construction of a request
such as passive versus active voices or
questions versus statements
this will help represent the variety of
ways a user might say an intent when
creating an intent the more training
phrases you can think of the better
later we will discuss best practices for
writing your training phrases entities
help you get to the specifics of an
interaction in dialog the entities are
the nouns or quantifiers found through
the conversation such as a person's name
the food in a review of a crews specific
numbers or dates just to name a few when
you are creating an entity and you
identify that the entity contains
attributes that you need to map to one
way is to use composite entities for our
ordering pizza example let's say that we
want to create an intent for ordering
pizza a pizza could be of type regular
or thin crust regular and thin crust in
this case both our entries in an entity
called pizza system entities are
pre-built entities provided by dialogue
flow in order to facilitate handling the
most popular concepts use one of the
system entities to represent date and
time for example or others such as
addresses currency units numbers and
many others contexts allow the agent to
keep track of where the user is at in
the conversation in the context of
dialogue flow there are also a means for
an application to store and access
variables mentioned in the dialog in
this example of ordering pizza
if the senate's actually make that two
hours is set out of context there is no
way that the agent can know that the
user is referring to the pickup time for
the pizza order the context in this
conversation ensures that your dialogue
flow agent knows that this request is
related to the Pizza ordering intent for
the pizza example we built our agent
step by step starting with creating
intents followed by entities and then
contexts all done within the dialog flow
UI sometimes you may already have
existing sources that you can connects
tracked entities from for instance a
call center playbook or an FAQ document
so we look at ways to leverage this data
when building our agent sometimes all
you need is a conversation interface to
surface answers from the existing
back-end systems and capabilities and so
we look at deploying your back-end code
as a web hook on App Engine we also look
at how to customize your agents UI so
that you can have your own branding this
is where we deploy a custom front-end on
App Engine we also want to secure our
web hooks so it only makes off entik
ated calls to the back-end services in
our course we start with a Pizza
ordering example where the backend is
meant to store pizza orders so you're
mainly writing into the database then we
move on to an HR manual example where
the backend is a knowledge base where a
query will look up for definitions and
send it back to the user so you're
mainly reading from the database so how
do we build this knowledge base in the
first place we use an employee handbook
which is an HR manual document with
topic keywords and definitions so all we
need to do is leverage that to build our
knowledge base in the hands-on lab we
use cloud data lab notebooks to quickly
run Python scripts to extract topics
from the sample HR manual then push them
into a data store entity using the cloud
datastore API next we use Google's
natural language API to form synonyms of
these topics and add them to datastore
finally we call the dialogue flow API to
then populate your dialogue flow agents
entity list with these topics from the
datastore entity the demo that follows
will walk you through the steps covered
so far so I will pull up our demo screen
and I will maximize it so I've already
done some of the setup work for the demo
that you would do in the lab so I've
already created a data Lab instance this
is actually a compute engine VM that
hosts our data lab notebooks so that's
already up and running so now we can
preview our data lab notebooks so I'll
go to web preview and change the port to
80 81 change in preview and I already
cloned the data lab notebooks that we
will need to use so the first one that
we're going to look at is process
Handbook so I'll click that and I'll do
clear all cells to make sure that we
have a fresh start and then I can
execute these cells one by one so we'll
make sure that we have the right version
of cloud datastore
then I'm going to make sure that that
new version gets restarted and now we
can look at our code for processing the
handbook so I'm going to run these cells
one by one so I'm importing the
datastore library and then this is what
will actually extract our topics and
their definitions from this HR manual
text file so I'll run this block of code
and we can see that it's extracting the
different headings which are our topics
from that text file now we're going to
do basically the same thing with the
synonyms notebook so this will just
generate synonyms for all of the topics
that we just extracted so I'm opening
the process synonyms notebook going to
clear this one and do the same thing so
we'll make sure that we have the correct
version of datastore
and then reset the session to make sure
that that takes effect and now we will
import the NLT kay library to generate
our synonyms
and we'll import datastore in this
notebook as well so this is going to
look at the data store entities that we
already have named under topic and it's
going to use the in ltk library to
generate synonyms for those entities so
we'll run this block of code and there
it goes
generating synonyms for all of our
topics so this might take a second
and in data lab the way that we know
that a cell is finished running is this
side bar will turn from gray to blue so
that will let us know that it's
completely finished with that block of
code so we'll have to wait for that
looks like we're getting a lot of
synonyms for these topics should be
almost done
towards the end of the alphabet now and
our sidebar there turned to blue so that
one's finished so now we will actually
call the Google natural language API to
evaluate the salience of each of these
topic keywords to determine how relevant
they are to the overall context so we'll
run each of these cells and this is what
will actually push all of the synonyms
that we just generated into datastore as
well
so we can see this is going through the
different topics and evaluating their
salience in the overall context of the
document and so that cell is finished so
now we can look at datastore and see how
those got pushed into our datastore
kinds so I can go to datastore in the
GCP console and I see we should have two
kinds so we have topic this is all of
the actual keywords that were extracted
from the HR manual and then we can
switch over to synonym these are all of
the synonyms that were generated from
those topics and also pushed to
datastore so those are all set so now I
can go to the dialogue flow console
itself and I've already created my agent
and when I created it I imported an
existing project so I imported this same
project that I have my datastore topics
and synonyms in so that they're matched
up and connected and so now that that is
set up I can go back to my data lab
notebooks and look at this dialogue flow
notebook
and I'm going to clear this one just to
make sure it's fresh and we will run
this cell to install the correct version
of dialogue flow and then I'm going just
for a good measure I'm going to do a
restart to make sure that that gets
incorporated into this notebook and then
we can pick back up here so this
dialogue flow notebook will actually
take all of the entities that we created
in datastore and import them into our
dialogue flow agent okay so that's done
so now I can switch back to the dialogue
flow console and I can click on entities
and create one so I'm going to name it
topic I'll uncheck define synonyms
because we did that in our notebook and
I'll just enter a test value for now as
a placeholder so I'll hit save so that
it creates that entity actually I may
need to run that dialogue flow notebook
again since I had created the entity yet
so let me restart that so we'll do clear
and I should be able to just pick up
here
okay let's check it now and see if that
worked so when you refresh here and
there they are
so that dialogue flow notebook actually
took all of these entities that we had
in datastore and they're synonyms and
put them in our matching topic entity
and dialogue flow so now we're going to
look at intense so I can create a new
intent and I'm just going to name this
one topic as well and I need to allow
this intent to be able to be looked up
so I'm going to create an action under
the intent and I'm just going to call it
lookup and I'll name the parameter name
topic and then I'm going to connect it
to that topic entity that we created so
it shows up there and then the value
will also be topic and for a fulfillment
I am going to go ahead and enable
fulfillment because we're going to
enable a webhook call for this intent so
all of that is set up so I'll save that
and now I'll add a couple of trading
phrases so these are what we talked
about in the presentation so this is
what we can start with just a few so
that the agent can kind of know how this
topic entity will be called from the
topic intent so we can just give it one
or two for now so that it gets a quick
idea so I'm going to say tell me about
annual salary and before I exit out of
that I'm going to highlight the term
annual salary so I just click and drag
there and I'm going to make sure it
knows that this is calling my topic
entity so I'll hit enter and then I'll
add one more I'll do what is discipline
discipline is another term from our HR
manual and I'll do the same thing with
that topic entity so that should be good
to start with so I can hit save
and you can see this dialogue here
popping up saying agent training started
so we'll wait for that to finish it
should give us a completed message when
it's done there we go
agent training completed okay so now I
can switch back to my presentation since
we have all of that groundwork set up
okay so this is what we just did so now
we can talk about App Engine App Engine
is Google's fully managed server list
platform as a service product that
allows you to build highly scalable
applications the underlying
infrastructure is taken care of for you
with support for multiple programming
languages App Engine enables developers
to focus on developing their
applications without needing to worry
about infrastructure concerns you can
deploy your web hook to App Engine by
running the g-cloud app deploy command
App Engine will find your app dot yamo
file for your service
read any additional parameters that you
set such as version number runtime and
service name and deploy your application
to run your app locally before pushing
it to production you can run the dev app
server dot PI command for example to
test your Python app from cloud shell so
in our HR chatbot example the web hook
is called by the dialog flow agents
fulfillment component to get answers
from datastore once a topic entity is
matched the webhook code uses
information from the HTTP POST request
sent by your agent to look up the
keyword and match it with the topic
entity in cloud datastore
the web hook will then return a response
back to the user which contains the
definition of the keyword passed in the
request so we'll go back to the demos
and take a quick look at the webhook
code so I will pull back up my demo tab
okay and so now the notebook that will
run is our webhook notebook so I can
open this one up and we'll clear it just
to be safe and now we can run these
cells one by one
okay and then this is what we actually
need to create a web hook for our
fulfillment component of our dialog flow
agent so one way to do this is from this
data lab notebook we can click this
drop-down next to notebook and we could
do something like convert to Python
so that would convert everything in this
data lab notebook into an actual
executable python script and then we
could deploy that to App Engine
so that's exactly what we did in this
project so if I open a new tab in my
cloud show and I can look for that
Python script
okay so I called it mean dot pie
actually I can look at this from the
code editor because that will be a
better way to see it so I'm opening the
code editor from cloud shell and I have
my folder I already created so I'll go
into webhook and we can look at the main
dot pie file so this is the exact same
thing that was in our data lab notebook
we just saw but it's just created as a
Python script so this is how we can
deploy this Python app into App Engine
so let me go to App Engine so we can see
the dashboard and we need to initialize
App Engine really quick so we will let
me do select an existing project so I'll
choose this one
confirm project next so we don't need to
do this tutorial so I'm going to cancel
out of it what that should have
initialized our App Engine setup so now
we can actually deploy that webhook on
to App Engine so let me take a look at
the App DMO this is what will deploy
this service into App Engine so for now
I'm going to remove this service name
because our first service on App Engine
needs to be the default so we will take
out that named service name for now and
let me make sure I'm still in the right
directory okay so now I can do g-cloud
app deploy so this is going to deploy
all of our webhook code we just saw on
App Engine
shouldn't take too long
so app engine is automatically taking
care of a lot of stuff for us like
updating the service and setting traffic
split for the service automatically so
now it has finished deploying so I'll
switch back to the App Engine dashboard
let me click on services
I'll do it refresh and see if that hopes
okay so now we've got it so at this
point we don't have a UI for our service
so when we click this we won't see
anything yet it's just going to say not
found but we can grab this URL and we
can switch back over to the dialog flow
console and we'll go back to the
fulfillment so up here I'm going to
enable web hook and then I'm going to
paste that URL in an add web hook at the
end and then we had already set the
username and password for basic off in
that web hook code so I will enter that
here and then I can scroll down and hit
save so now we should have a deployed
web hook that's hosted on App Engine
that our dialogue flow agent is calling
so let me try tell me about annual
salary which was one of our training
phrases and we see the default response
so this is the response that is from
that HR manual text file that we
extracted all of the topics and
definitions out of into datastore and
then push them into our dialog flow
agent and it is calling a hosted web
hook on App Engine that is secured with
basic auth on the backend so that is the
idea let me switch back to our
presentation
okay so a quick recap of some things we
just did we added HTTP basic
authentication to our web hooks to
prevent unauthorized access and so this
ensures that unauthorized callers can't
call our web hook and in the web hook
code we implemented flasks security
framework for HTTP basic authentication
so this requires off method requires
authentication to access our app and we
had a check off method which validates
the submitted username and password so
these username and password values in
this code snippet are what we used in
the dialogue flow console and then the
authenticate method sends a 401 response
if authentication fails and so we also
had to add this requires a decorator to
our handle method to ensure that the
method validates those authorization
credentials so besides having a
customized front-end dialogue flow
agents can also be enabled in multiple
channels and surfaces from text to voice
to phone so beyond the web chat core
feature which we saw when we tested it
out in the console you can use the
built-in feature for deploying your
agent onto any Google assistant enabled
device such as the assistant mobile app
or a Google home device so you can also
easily integrate your dialogue flow
agent into other third-party apps like
Facebook Messenger Twitter and slack and
there are also import and export
capabilities for easily importing your
dialogue flow agent into Amazon Alexa or
Microsoft Cortana compatible files
so while dialogue flow gives you several
surface options from the dialogue flow
console web interface to Google
assistant to Google home devices these
all rely on the actions SDK for creating
the actions that form your agent this
allows you to seamlessly move between
surfaces for the same agent no matter
which platform or functionality you need
so a quick recap of our course and some
things that we just previewed
conversation is the new UI and it's very
quickly changing the way that users
communicate with businesses employers
and other
we looked at some of the challenges when
creating conversational agents that can
handle natural language input and
discussed how dialogue flow can address
some of these concerns and through the
life of a conversation we looked at some
of the essential elements that you want
your chat bot to have like intense
entities context and fulfillment you
also learned how to define intents and
entities using the dialogue flow UI and
in the HR chat bot example we leveraged
an existing data source to extract
entities from your dialogue flow agent
and we learned that being able to
maintain context is important for the
agent to be able to control the flow and
minimize repetition and improve overall
satisfaction and with fulfilment you can
add functionality like connecting to
back-end systems we then saw the coming
together of GCP products to
productionize your agent like deploying
your webhook on App Engine so it can
scale building a knowledge base in cloud
datastore by leveraging the HR manual
and using the natural language API to
generate synonyms and adding security
and then towards the end we talked about
how you can easily integrate your agent
into other surfaces like the Google
assistant and demonstrated some of the
newer additional features and one last
thing before we go to Q&A
remember to claim your free month of
Google cloud specializations on Coursera
for any of our specialization courses
including data engineering architecting
and developing applications and a lot
more by going to this link or scanning
this QR code and look for our
full-length building conversational
experiences with dialog flow course
launching on Coursera soon so we are
ready for Q&A
stay tuned for live Q&A we'll be back in
less than a minute
you
okay so we are back with some questions
from the audience for dialogue flow and
everything that we just talked about so
let's look at the first question we use
dotnet or any other development platform
can I use dialog flow from our
environment so the answer to that one is
yes so the example that I showed and
that we we talked about in the Coursera
course is all using Python but that is
definitely not the only option there are
a ton of different dialogue flow
fulfillment libraries that are available
and a lot of them are already written
and ready to use on dialogue flows
github page so we have dotnet nodejs
Java Python c-sharp and Ruby I think
those are the ones I don't believe I've
left any out but the answer is yes
definitely and then of course another
option would also be just to use the
REST API calls to use the dialogue flow
interface okay so second question we
have developed our own specialized
speech to text or use another third
parties can I use it with dialogue flow
so the answer to that one is also yes
because of that rest API integration you
can integrate your own speech to text
API with dialogue flow speech to text
API so that would would definitely work
so I guess we didn't get any other
questions so I will go ahead and close
us out so I think that's it for our
dialogue flow course stay tuned for the
next session
CET V machine learning 101 the what why
and how of ml thank you
you
[Music]
you